[Music]
i think it's very important that we
as packer fans because i was a fan long
before i was blair but we as packer fans
and packer people i think we need to
honor mike and respect him the right way
we had a hell of a run we had 13 years
four nfc championships one super bowl
eight straight playoffs 19 straight wins
we did some incredible things so instead
of trashing this guy on the way out
let's remember the amazing times that we
had together
that's aaron rodgers on espn milwaukee
yesterday it kind of felt like terrell
owens with the sunglasses on saying you
you can give tony aroma a hard time for
going to mexico during the bye week if
you want but sniff sniff that's my
quarterback there was a little just a
little bit of passive aggressive in that
defensive mic with just a little bit of
passive aggressive and that was just a
part of what aaron rodgers had to say on
monday on espn milwaukee he did not do a
media scrum yet they've started their
offseason program in green bay chris but
uh this was his chance in a friendly
environment to say what he wanted to say
he was very aggressive very strident
attacked people like greg jennings and
michael finley for consistently having
negative things to say about aaron
rodgers attacked tyler dunn of bleacher
reports saying that it was a a smear
campaign and it it's it's aimed at it
boosting the writer's career and
questioning the use of unnamed sources
and whatnot and all in all you know
after a few days of this dying down
aaron rodgers really brought it back
with a vengeance on monday and you know
as always the truth probably resides
somewhere in the middle yeah and listen
you know aaron rodgers i always like the
fact that he i mean he he keeps it real
for lack of a better phrase i mean he's
not afraid to you know throw around his
opinions or things that he's thought of
and throw out you know facts of the
matter whatever it may be yeah no he he
attacked you know you know uh what you
said unnamed sources say listen unnamed
sources again people can attack them all
they want they're part of the industry
they're part of the media that's just
the way it is i mean we can't do that
sometimes sometimes i'm told stuff by a
high ranking official on a team that's a
hundred percent true accurate they don't
want their their uh name being thrown in
there and i have to say something on tv
you know yeah i talked to a source okay
yeah you know me you vet me you go
through that and that's what makes the
world go around here at times does it
become a little loose of time certainly
but i appreciate rogers kind of taking
uh the situation head-on i also do
appreciate the fact that he you know
made light of the mike mccarthy
situation a little bit in the sense that
you know it is a piling on session by
mike mccarr on mike mccarthy right now
and listen i've been one guy too that's
certainly been harsh on mike mccarthy i
don't like his offense i think that it's
a it's an elementary offense i've had an
issue with that all along but i do like
that rogers kind of brings back the
green bay fans back to reality and says
hey let's appreciate this guy what he
did he also makes a point too about you
know if i hated mike mccarthy so much in
this interview then why did i sign this
new contract you know i didn't sign this
because i was miserable and i wanted to
be miserable with a guy forever which i
thought was also another interesting
point that kind of uh has been swept
under the rug here in this conversation
no no but let's not let's not swim under
the rug let's consider the context right
at the time aaron rodgers was under
contract for two more years and he had
been leapfrogged by
andrew luck derek carr jimmy garoppolo
kirk cousins matt ryan and and and then
eventually aaron rodgers he would
leapfrog all of them but he was eight
million dollars per year behind matt
ryan it was glaring it was embarrassing
he needed a new contract and surely he
knew going into the 2018 season that
there's a way the dominoes fall that
mike mccarthy gets fired the handwriting
was on their wall they pushed out ted
thompson mark murphy took direct
responsibility for mike mccarthy and i
think rogers is smart enough to know
that this is potentially something
that's going to happen and i've got my
new contract i get a new coach and i'm
set for the final four or five years of
my career so i think that argument why
did i sign a new contract i think that's
a red herring because it's a completely
different circumstance and whether or
not mike mccarthy was going to be the
coach and i think once you sign aaron
rodgers to that big contract you make it
even more likely if there is dysfunction
between the two guys mccarthy's the one
who's going to get run out the door yeah
i get that but also you got to play the
fact that aaron rodgers is going i'm
going to sign this new contract and you
know i'm going to be awesome and we're
going to be awesome and we're going to
make the playoffs again and he's going
to figure that that guy's got to be
stuck with him as far as mike mccarthy
is concerned who i'm talking about being
stuck with him uh for a long period of
time i don't think he was looking at it
going i'm gonna sign this new contract
we'll go six and ten and i'll get him
out of here so you know i'm just i'm
just adding food or food bertha
go ahead i hear what you're saying i
hear what you're saying but here's
here's what we have to consider about
aaron rodgers i think at his core
he either wants he desperately wants to
be loved by everyone or hated by no one
or both and i don't think he is wired to
pick that kind of a public fight unless
he's backed into a corner like he was by
this bleacher report item from tyler
dunn he did not want to be reviled like
like brett favre was in green bay he
does not want to try to talk his way out
of town he doesn't want to play the kirk
cousins leverage game with the franchise
tag one year after another he wanted
green bay to take care of him
financially because he had been
leapfrogged by six or seven other
quarterbacks and they did he was never
going to force his way out of green bay
so the next best thing he was not at
some point they force out mike mccarthy
so we have to understand all this from
that context of who aaron rodgers is
he's not a guy who was ever going to
force his way out of green bay that's
where he wants to stay until they tell
him
we are done with you and we're moving on
yeah well yes i mean nobody really wants
to do that i mean you know when you've
set up you know camp as one of the
franchise's all-time greatest
quarterbacks and you know really a name
and face that is synonymous with that
organization and the album on the helmet
no quarterback wants to leave town after
that you built something special there
so yeah you're gonna stay there forever
um and and you know of course roger's
wanted a new contract we know all of
that yes i mean gosh he had guys that
aren't even in the same stratosphere as
him making uh considerably more money
you know and and the other thing here
too hey again is aaron rodgers a little
sensitive uh yes he is and as he makes
some passive aggressive comments yes he
has but to me i sit here as a guy who
has no
vested interest other than thinking the
guy's awesome at football i don't sit
here and look at oh this is a bad leader
guy i mean a guy that is a bad leader
that leads his team down to victory in
the end of every fourth quarter and
everybody on his team in the history
believes he's unbelievable except for
two guys ninja michael finley and greg
jennings everybody else's speaks
glowingly about him so that's where i
stick up for rogers too and i understand
the sensitivity because
everybody talks about how awesome he is
and yet if he doesn't win
everybody just blames him nobody ever
talks about oh the packers defense
stinks whatever it's always all rogers
is so overrated rogers has only won one
super bowl so yes because of the
environment and the culture he's been
stuck in in green bay where he's asked
to carry the team change the plays when
according uh when when you know when it
makes sense and all of those things he's
felt like he's probably had to stick up
for himself a little bit here and there
throughout the last few years too
because he does get a lot of the
criticism that goes around
peyton manning played in the nfl for a
long time have we ever heard any former
teammates on or off the record saying
anything bad about peyton manning yes we
ever heard anyone's not on the record
but i've heard plenty off yes i have
well and you know why we don't hear it
on the record right and this is a key
element of leadership and i'm not saying
i endorse this but if you want to be and
not look there's different ways to lead
but one way to lead
is to lead by fear and i think that
people teammates were afraid of peyton
manning not that he's going to come beat
anyone up but that he will be relentless
and he will get you and he will call you
up and he he is not conflict diverse
like aaron rodgers but look at look at
manning look at brady look at some of
the great true natural leaders
you don't have people calling them out
publicly by name we see it with ben
roethlisberger we see it with aaron
rodgers and i don't know if that whole
passive aggressive vibe if you're not
going to be confrontational with someone
maybe that makes guys emboldened that
they're going to say what they want to
say about you because you aren't a guy
who's going to lead by grabbing someone
by the shirt caller and telling them
what they need to do and i again i'm not
endorsing that style i'm just making a
comment here that something allows
former teammates to be comfortable
enough to call out aaron rodgers and
call out ben roethlisberger when
really of all the great franchise quote
i mean drew brees no one's ever said a
word about him tom brady no one says
anything russell wilson they said stuff
behind his back because there's nothing
to his face because they're not anointed
kings of their organizations like aaron
rodgers and big ben roethlisberger is
and it's not necessarily their fault you
know that's what i want to say there yet
tom brady didn't have to instill the
fear in people really early on okay
because he had bill belichick he had
people do that he got to grow into the
spot russell wilson the same thing i
mean they were hey russell be careful
with the ball make a play here and there
hand the ball off to march on lynch
we'll play defense and that's the way
it'll work and pete carroll the defense
led the team that way so you know again
culture and what you're brought up in is
also part of what creates the things we
don't like about aaron rodgers that's
where i push back at times because he
has been asked from day one to do a lot
of different things as compared to let's
just say a tom brady or drew brees who
have quote coaches who are you know
they're tyrants they're they're they're
they're generals they're they're the
ones that are driving the the fear of
the ship and keeping everybody on edge
and sean payton and bill belichick and i
just don't think that was the case up in
green bay it was a culture already of
brett favre you carry the team you're
the squad and then it got transitioned
right over to aaron rodgers and then he
became special and it became even more
than that where they were just like damn
this guy is good hey aaron just go out
there and make plays and make it happen
and you know hopefully we can win the
game and that's really what he's asked
to do and of course that feeds the ego
and maybe some of the things we don't
like too about aaron rodgers
his approach definitely has been one of
passive aggressive and you know a couple
of years ago he called me out because he
had said two things that i thought were
clear examples of a passive aggressive
attack against mike marthy mike mccarthy
he said uh one week after a game there
isn't enough energy on the sidelines
during the game well that's the
responsibility of the coach he didn't
say that but it was obvious that was his
point and then he said there isn't a
healthy fear among the players if you
don't do your job you're going to lose
your job and again it's the
responsibility of the coach to instill
that fear and i mention all that because
he did express regret for one not maybe
even more than passive aggressive attack
on the offense last year when they beat
the bills 22 to nothing here is what
rogers had to say about the offensive
performance after that victory
that's just not acceptable offense for
us
four and 23 yards looks pretty good in
comparison to some of the
games we've uh
before the first three weeks but uh
should have been about 45 points and
about 600 yards
he said on espn milwaukee yesterday i
wish i hadn't said anything after the
bills game i wish i had just gotten with
mccarthy in person i wasn't trying to be
disrespectful to him but i know how it
came off that's what i told him when i
met with him face to face but yeah and
you could if you're watching on tv
there's a little bit of a smirk there i
mean that's the way he's handled these
things he'll go to the media and he'll
make that kind of a smart alecky comment
with that that little gleam in his eye
and that little half smile on his face
that's how he's always done things and
it caught up to him finally with this
tyler dunn report because even though he
has vehemently denied it he was clearly
against the ropes for multiple days i'm
surprised he waited for four days before
he said anything because this really got
baked into the weekend and we emerged
from the weekend it's like oh well yeah
that's what we saw last week about aaron
rodgers and mike mccarthy we just kind
of move on but uh i i you know he always
has that smirk on his face though
whether it's a serious is that like
that's what we're we're taking it just
with the context of the situation and
again what was wrong that he said there
i mean what was wrong why do you
apologize then because because he felt
maybe that it added to the conversation
about mike mccarthy and the offense
maybe that's why he's just feeling
guilty about it but again i just think
if other quarterbacks made those
comments that time said we want to do
better we should have had more yards he
didn't say anybody's name he said the
offense should have done better he's
trying to hold everything accountable
again maybe he could have phrased it
differently i don't know
but here's a guy that again you talked
about he's not he might be afraid of
confrontation where i want to say he's
more confrontational than the people
you've talked about i mean he's not
afraid to call out people and coaches
and be that leader you're talking about
and yet when it doesn't work out exactly
how we all wanted to
and now one or two guys are mad about it
we go well maybe he's not a leader okay
so i don't know yeah
i i think it is it is an example of poor
leadership to say anything negative like
that out in the open you you stick with
the cliches i know it's better for our
business if they don't but the smart
move for the quarterback is stick with
the cliches look at how tom brady
handles his business don't say anything
that would reflect negatively on anyone
directly or indirectly and deal with any
concerns you have in the locker room or
yell at people on the sidelines and then
we have images of it and we're like oh
look at tom brady yelling at somebody
but he you never hear tom brady take a
shot directly or indirectly at anyone or
anything
in that press conference setting and i
think that's the example that other
quarterbacks should follow because we
and they the the teammates the coaches
they interpret every word the guy says
and they're looking for that slight
remember when peyton manning said i'm
trying to be a good teammate here but we
have issues in protection right and
everybody lost their minds right that
was nothing compared to the things
rogers has said over the past few years
well i i don't know you know again why
well tell me what he said that's so so
much worse i've heard plenty of press
conferences where tom brady has talked
about man we got to play better you know
the offense didn't play good so we just
too many mistakes things like that you
know why is that any different than what
aaron rodgers just said right there i
don't i don't understand that you know
again i've heard a lot of quarterbacks
say that i just think we no we're we
think it's weird because mike mccarthy's
been fired and we knew there was issues
there but i think a lot of quarterbacks
make comments like that through the year
every year that quote don't like their
their performances
i can't imagine i want to go back to
2016. i can't imagine tom brady ever
saying publicly there isn't enough
energy on the sidelines and i can't
imagine him ever saying that there needs
to be a healthy fear in the locker room
that if you don't do your job you're not
going to have a job i can't imagine tom
brady saying that in a thousand years i
guess and i can't imagine bill belichick
acting like mike mccarthy so i
understand that's what happens sometimes
when the when you have bill belichick
you don't have to do some of the things
that aaron rodgers has and now i don't
mean i'm not being a jerk on tom brady
he's the man we got to go to commercial
but i just get sick of this crap with
aaron rodgers at times too i think it's
out of both both both sides of our mouth
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports